hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from yesterday's Champions
Chester finals it's a game or rather
round three this is game two of round
three Fabiano corana versus Magnus
Carlson their first game ended in a draw
and uh this one most certainly did not
and you will see something that quite
often happens when people face the likes
of Magnus Carlson why does this happen
we have no idea some call it the Magnus
effect some you know attributed to other
things but it does happen and it does
happen quite often so let's check it out
Fabiano has the white pieces and he
opens with E4 uh Magnus goes for Knight
to C6 this is called the nimich defense
and it is something that you you don't
usually play against a strong player and
you especially don't play it against the
former World chest Championship
Challenger uh Fabiano corana we have D4
and now D5 this is so-called the
Scandinavian variation of the NIMS of
which because you can easily transpose
into the Scandinavian with captures
captures and now you have the D4 line of
the Scandinavian if if you don't prefer
prer to go for for the immediate Knight
to C3 H but okay of course you don't
play that E5 by Fabby we have Bishop to
F5 and now Knight to F3 we have Pawn to
E6 closing up the light squares as
you've developed your light Square
bishop and Bishop to D3 now offering a
trade Magnus trades and now just Queen
to D7 so it's a very natural way of
developing you put your pawns on light
squares you have a dark Square Bishop to
complement them uh you know uh on on the
squares that they are not covering you
you've developed your queen and Knight
and you will Castle Queen side whereas
Fabby has a very natural development
also controlling the center he will
probably Castle King side and it's a
nice game so we have Pawn to C3 and
Magnus immediately goes after the center
with Pawn to F6 uh Fabby castles and now
uh there are some games for F5 and
Knight G to E7 were played but Magnus
just trades in the center and it is now
as of move eight that we have a
completely new game so okay Fabby
captures back c cap D captur on E5 and
we have Pawn to A5 stopping Pawn to B4
uh Rook to E1 adding more more support
to the E5 pawn and just Bishop to C5 it
could be uh coming very handy as the
file has opened up and if you put the
Rooks on the f file uh the white king
might feel the the pressure a little bit
so Knight B to D2 We have Pawn to A4
stopping B4 but not really as that is
exactly what Fabby plays interestingly
the engine gives Knights to G5 with a
with a pretty pretty heavy Advantage for
uh White because the E6 Pawn is very
weak and by doing this you kind of
prevent black from Ever playing H6 and
also you free up the F3 Square for the
other Knight you can put it to D4 to
further pressure E6 and you will force
some trades on the D4 Square which will
favor white as white will improve the
center with c cap on D4 but okay as this
is um uh yeah sorry about that I forgot
to change the letter on the little robot
this is a rapid game so let me just uh
fix that some of you guys might be
watching this and are like what isn't
this isn't this a rapid game uh there we
go uh so as it's a rapid game of course
you don't spot every little thing but
yeah A4 Fabby played B4 uh and now a
captures on B3 alasan we have a knight
captures on B3 pressuring the bishop
here and Bishop to B6 so Faby counters
the bishop and Magnus trades Bishop
captures Rook captures and now Pawn to
B6 not allowing the knight any Knight to
C5 action uh we have Knight to G5 now
from Fabby and Knight G to E7 hoping to
get the Knight to F5 uh and Fabby now
has to decide does he capture on H7 or
is it maybe a bit too much giving Magnus
the semi-open H file uh interestingly it
is the top move recommended by the
engine and you know that fabbi always
plays that top move recommended by the
engine so he goes for it Knight captures
on H7 not afraid of the boogeyman we
have Knight to F5 going after the Rook
uh Rook to H3 you have to defend your
Rook because now the queen is no longer
doing that job and now uh you you
probably expect something like Knight
captures on E5 it's what you would play
it's what I would play is the strongest
uh move recommended by the engine it
just looks so uh clean Knight captures
attacks the Queen the queen moves you
put the Knight somewhere on G6 let's say
but not Magnus he plays King to d8 he
just wants to put his King to to B7 and
enjoy an attack on the king side not
really caring about that um E5 pawn and
now if Fabi wasn't impressed by this
King to d8 move and if anyone else
played it other than Magnus he would
just play Pawn to F4 defend the pawn and
the game continues nothing spectacular
happening here but because Magnus played
it Fabby says all right F4 might not be
such a great idea or he probably thought
that maybe Magnus uh had something else
in mind maybe he was just bluffing uh
all that being said he he does not play
Pawn to F4 he goes Pawn to A4 and now
Magnus just captures on E5 so now Knight
captures on E5 attacks the queen queen
to E2 and now Knight to G6 now the uh
Rook is defended so you don't have to
worry if the Knight moves uh Queen to G4
and now Knight to E5 5 further harassing
the queen queen to F4 and Knight back to
F7 now uh we have Pawn to A5 and now
King to C8 by Magnus and again if this
was anyone else Fabby would just trade
here for example a captures on B6 Brook
captures on A1 with check Knight
captures Pawn captures and that's it
okay let's say Knight to C2 the Knight
wants to join the attack the king will
be placed on B7 and the game continues
with um uh you know chances for both
sides however after King to C8 Fabby
played Rook to E1
and uh Magnus said uh okay thank you for
the free pass pawn and played B captures
on A5 and now the idea of Knight to C5
going after the queen and the E6 Pawn
doesn't look all that impressive but
even though it doesn't look all that
impressive it is by far the best uh a
plan Fabby could go for because after
Knight to C5 uh the reason why he didn't
go for is that after Queen to D6 okay
you win this Pawn night captures on E6
Queens get traded off captures captures
uh the problem is uh there's Knight five
to H6 and the Knight here is trapped
there's no square for the Knight and you
will lose that piece but even with this
it is best for Fabby to go for this line
because he will also take the two pawns
he will play Knight captures on D5 not
right away he will first go
for uh Rook to H5 to go after the pawns
this way and only after you capture
because now you are also threatening to
bring the Knight back with Knight to G5
Magnus will have to capture you will
then capture on uh first you will go
Rook the8 to check you will trade off
the Rooks captures captures now you're
going to capture this pawn and next
going to capture this Pawn or if Pawn A4
Rook A5 check will capture this pawn and
you will have uh two pawns for a knight
which is you know not great but it does
give you best drawing chances however
after B captures on A5 uh he just played
Queen back to D2 uh he wants to organize
a defense against the past a pawn and
that will be what this game is about now
and now Magnus starts pushing Pawn to E5
we have Rook to A1 going after the pawn
here Queen B5 defending and attacking
here Queen to C2 defending the the
Knight and now Knight 7 to D6 we have
Knight back to D2 and now Pawn to A4
Magnus just continues uh happily
advancing his past Pawn to Victory and
now Fabby plays Pawn to G4 you have to
you have to make something happen Knight
back to E7 and now Knight to F3 going
after the E5 Pawn but just Knight to C4
nicely defending the pawn uh we have
Knight F to G5 and now Pawn to A3 Magnus
continues advancing the pawn Knight F7
uh and now just Rook to E8 with have
Knight H to G5 finally getting this
Knight back into the game and queen to
B2 Magnus now offers a rook trade a
queen trade and you cannot go for this
as the the pass B Pawn will be too
powerful so Queen to D1 was played Now
Pawn to A2 and that's pretty much all
there is the pass Pawn is now much too
much too powerful as all the even all
the tactics work in in magnus's favor we
have Knight to E6 now comes Queen to B6
putting pressure on the Knight and here
Knight F back to G5 defending the knight
uh also could capture the pawn here but
then Rook G8 also doesn't look that
impressive so Knight F to G5 was played
uh and now just Pawn to E4 now Magnus
continues pushing in the center as well
as this diagonal looks very interesting
King to G2 and now Rook to A5 just
adding another Defender here uh we have
Knight captures on G7 finally winning
that pawn but now Rook to f8 putting
pressure on that F2 Pawn so you really
need to defend it Queen to E2 defending
the pawn and now Magnus played Queen to
B1 and he was in this position on move
39 that Fabiano corana resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh the first game ended in a draw second
game was won by Magnus with the black
pieces which means Magnus wins um the
match and also uh he defeated Hikaru
Nakamura in the second match he drew the
first two rapid games and then he won in
Armageddon uh which is uh something very
few people have accomplished defeating
Fabiano corana and hikaro Nakamura on
the same day uh but yeah that is uh that
is just uh you know just Magnus things
so here you resign because uh Queen
captures on A1 will win you The Rook of
course if you capture the queen then
just uh you bring another queen into the
game and other than that then there's
really not much you can try if you go
something back Queen T1 you simply trade
here captures captures and you bring a
Queen into the game white will have to
give up a rook and now you're just going
to be up a full Rook so whatever you do
here you're just dead lost so of course
after Queen B1 he resigned and a very
nice victory for Magnus Carlson once
again uh displaying the Magnus effect
where even a player uh you know a former
28 not a former a current 2800 like
Fabiano Coran and also a former World CH
Championship Challenger uh Falls a
victim to the deadly Magnus effect where
you you just don't trust yourself enough
to play against Magnus uh so that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it if you
have any other favorites from rounds
three or four do use ash suggestion and
I will gladly go over them I would like
to thank David gasparian Albert vardell
Nathan I love you Dad Milos kovich and T
formo for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your
day